lo and behold he's now part of a
tentpole of the NFL Network which is
game day which is a good morning
football every single day on NFL Network
at 7:00 a.m. and he's also on CBS the
NFL today against a and a morning on
Sunday I'm sorry I just that's just
unfortunately we have to promote Nate
Burleson you're on the show how are you
Nate I'm doing great
not better than you though man I'm very
happy for you and everything that's that
you've become Nate well I appreciate
that I'll tell you what man coming in in
2003 as we all know the very infancy
stage networks you know watching guys
like you and and busting your butt kind
of look up to certain guys in industry
man and you're you're one of the Titans
so you lead the way and let guys like us
follow Nate you're the man let's get
into it here my buddy Brockman and I
were just going out of here I'm not
going to reveal what we were going at
I'm just gonna throw it out right now
name the top five offenses in the NFL
that you would want to read total
missing that you would want to win a
game with right now in the month of
December and think that they have years
of success ahead of them
top five oh that last part of the
sentence really throws you off a little
bit I'm going with the Saints you got to
respect the fact that they dominate and
then we'll follow that up by the Rams
and the Chiefs yep after that yeah this
is where it gets tricky I'm on the New
England Patriots and then following
right afterwards it's a toss-up between
the Minnesota Vikings Steelers and the
Bears but I'm gonna go with the
Minnesota Vikings okay okay now why the
Vikings name why the Vikings would you
throw them in the world I'm looking at
the Vikings and Kirk Cousins has proved
to be worth every single dime they they
paid them and that was one of my biggest
concerns is there's no way a guy who
just came off of to franchise Ted is
making twenty four million apiece and
then he signs close to ninety million
dollars guarantee that he can fulfill
expectations with the team that was a
game away from winning the Superbowl but
in that game that he had up against
Aaron Rodgers wasn't perfect by any
means
but there are certain throws that he
made that just showed me that he can
take this offense and elevate them you
know you look at the players Adam
Thielen it's not that he wasn't born
last year but it's a different level
connection that he has with Kirk Cousins
and Stefon Diggs still planning a
phenomenal rate seems like the mini
miracle is just appetizer to wait the
thickness and then the surrounding
pieces ruff is a great red zone target
at Avis Murray and Dalvin cook is
looking like himself again it's going to
be a true test of course going up
against the Patriots and I feel like if
Kirk guns and go pull this off this is
the second time I'm playing Tom Brady I
believe last time was 2015 with the
Washington Redskins but this is
definitely a true test so so we'll see
what happens we can see now now I will
reveal the reason why I asked because I
wanted you to agree with me which you
did not Nate is I would throw the Bears
in there I think the Bears were top-five
offense Jordan Howard has disappeared
because he just doesn't fit the the
speed that's required in this offense
right now he suddenly is a guy but that
doesn't fit in a way obviously needing
to win some games in December using him
will come in handy and he might be the
old Jordan Howard eventually for some of
those games but right now I think that
they are dynamite and real fast and and
as good almost as everybody else in the
league Nate yeah there's a reason why I
brought them up I'm just I'm waiting a
hesitant and I and you know what to be
honest I think it's unfair for there to
be a yeah but when talking about the
Chicago Bears Matt naggy in his system
you look where Alex Smith in Kansas City
yeah and then him going to Chicago he
brought in the pieces that mimic that
office you know he has the speedy Taylor
Gabriel which is like his Kyrie kill he
has the tight end play at Ray Burton is
the host of wide receivers and guys
making plays at different levels and of
course to want to combination of Cohen
and how we're just like you're talking
about
I'm just waiting I'm waiting for them to
I don't want to say prove me wrong
because I do believe in that offense and
I do feel like with what mr. Brisky
brought to the table it proves that
athletic guy behind Center can really be
productive in that offense but chase
Daniel I mean going out there up against
my lines going to TDS and zero honest
like that proves right there that that
office assisting that scheme that Matt
naggy is bringing to the table it's just
as good as anybody in the league so the
last part is your question was for years
to come yep now if I consider that part
of the question more than the beginning
then yes that bears at the top of the
list because they're so young and all
those guys are very cheap do that's
about the same a person that humans
pronounced the name true Biscay as yeah
but I think you dicks pronounced true
Biscay not yeah but Nate that's the yeah
bug right that's the ultimate yeah but
but you know what we do know about mr.
risky is they can win games even when
he's not perfect and I made this point
on the show is that you know what we
can't appreciate about Satan he's doing
out there and he won a game without
throwing a pick we've seen true Brisky
throw interception and still the
combination of that fantastic offense in
that defense making plays still got
those guys to does Nate Burleson NFL
Network CBS right here on the Rich Eisen
show so who is your Super Bowl
prediction Danny have you changed in any
point in time on all your platforms Nate
yeah I have changed quite a bit
initially I went a Los Angeles and the
Chargers I went that Los Angeles Rams
and the Los Angeles to say you just LA
ok you're them both yeah ok LA westcote
Superbowl and you know I'm really not
gonna pull away from that one too much
together charges are still one of those
teams both was getting back Melvin
Gordon going down hurts a ton because I
thought he should be mentioned up there
with Todd Gurley but Phillip Rivers I
mean we just saw what he did that last
game he's playing at a high level
all these old G's of the game were
showing young pups how to do it but with
that said it's hard for me not to look
at the Patriots and believe that they're
gonna be in the AFC title game also the
Chiefs I mean they're just so damn good
and I do believe that Pat mahomes is our
MVP I mean as good as you breathe his
plan and boy if Pat mahomes keeps up
this I want this hot hot streak that
he's doing I believe he is gonna be on
VP so line I integrate in the very long
winter way yeah I would say the Rams for
sure no question I do have the ramps
coming out of NSC
I do believe they're gonna they're gonna
make it past the Saints and from there
it's between the T's in the past I know
I mean
breeze though in terms of MVP Nate I
mean come on he's just a goat and this
is not a Lifetime Achievement Award
either because he hasn't won it before
but what he's doing this year is off the
charts he is throwing it in windows the
size of a piece of paper to people that
he's probably never thrown to more than
a handful of times in practice it's
crazy what he's doing right now his plan
he's playing at a high level and you
know it's funny because last year are a
couple years ago we we complemented Matt
Ryan on that offensive now hit thirteen
guys so records equated to spread the
ball around is unheard of and Drew Brees
he hit 13 different guys touchdowns
which tied him for that NFL record and
I'm pretty sure that they're dialing up
something special peter ferrara so he's
like you know they got taken he'll still
well they also Brandon Marshall - I mean
some of those are the two that he's
probably gonna find at some point he's
gonna doubt it up the Teddy Bridgewater
ransack whatever it is whoever it is
guys are gonna come up with bad you can
say you know Sean Payton is dialing up
for sure because he wants to get another
one in the record fourth quarterback but
I do feel like there is a sentiment
though that it is oh well he hasn't
wanted I mean come on come on now it is
Drew Brees and what are you gonna tell
me if if Pat mahomes goes out there and
they don't lose another game he throws
for 50 touchdowns in an unbelievable
year which is really I know he's a
second year player but really his rookie
campaign you're not gonna give it to Pat
mahomes because Drew Brees is a legend
and he was the second-best
production-wise listen I am a Drew Brees
guy I think Drew Brees has heard me say
a thousand times there's only a handful
of quarterbacks I wish I play with you
top of the list but my homes is playing
out of this mind and at first it seemed
like it was just passing fad you know
alright no that's that young college the
running gun offense it's not gonna last
very gimmicky guess what some gimmick
lasts a long time and this one is
lasting throughout the season and I
can't wait for them to pick up after
their box yeah well let me let me just
continue this conversation I'm enjoying
it Nate Burleson here on the Rich Eisen
show drew
has as many interceptions on the season
right now Nate as Pat mahomes had in his
last two possessions of the last game he
played and he's got 29 touchdowns and 30
100 yards to boot and let me get this
one right here hold on a minute the
completion percentage it's positively
absurd at seventy six point four percent
so tonight he could hit on three-fourths
of his passes and that rate goes down
it's insane what he is doing at his age
as well this has nothing to do with a
like Scorsese winning for The Departed
you know this has nothing to do with the
fact that he hasn't gotten Awards before
no and we're not even talking about luck
either right now which is kind of nuts
as well he's definitely the dark words I
mean I believe that 32 touchdowns on the
season but here's the thing you're
hitting it on the money I mean through
breezes playing lights out because
completion percentage is probably better
than most of the guys shooting from free
throw in the NBA and the connection that
he has and Michael Thomas is
unbelievable we haven't even mentioned
that relationship which is gonna go down
as a record-breaking wide receiver from
quarterback Katz ratio but with all that
said you know touchdowns reign supreme
and wins reign supreme if if both teams
went out and Pat mahomes was tap-dancing
around 50 touchdowns and he catches a
heater and throws four five six TDs
which really isn't that hard to do for
Pat mahomes in that Kansas City awful
you have to give it to the young pup
because and here's here's that here's
the other side of the coin which is the
it's the kind of backhanded compliment
that you breathe we expect this from
Drew Brees I don't think people would
expect if we expect it from him
I mean you're right I guess we do come
on now like I don't think anybody was
gonna no no let's try the feature for
that long that's true man this is so
much fun it really is before I let you
go I won't hit you on the the topics du
jour in the NFL and that first up is the
Baker Mayfield extended handshake non
bro-hug DAP for Hugh and him
very vocal of what I think he is voicing
on behalf of every last one of his
teammates that Hugh wasn't was a little
bit Fugazi I'm wondering what you think
of Baker's comments and all of that I
loved it I loved every second of it and
it's not a shot at Hugh Jackson a lot of
guys that I played with play for you and
they love them I see him from a distance
I see him out in all season I'll dab
them up you know ask him how he's doing
but when it comes to Hugh Jackson how he
left the Browns I mean there's some
things that he said in the media when he
did a media tour and it was a little bit
of a shift of blame and and saying you
know they passed up on Watts and then
passed up on my homes and you know I was
dealing with second grade wide receivers
in yada yada yada
so if Baker Mayfield is hearing that and
he's a starting quarterback for a team
that was playing for you Jackson and I
know our coaches coach young players and
rookies he was probably walking and
talking about what the league is about
you know what rivalries are about and
things that he probably said about the
bangles and he got a ride or die for
these colors and Baker saying okay guys
we all know Baker wears his emotions on
his sleeve and he's fine and clay about
the passion he had so he takes things
literally and I'm okay with guys taking
things literally because most of the
guys that you see on TV they might not
necessarily care about the game as much
as you care about so fast in the back
saying you know what I don't like the
way Baker's handling it he should take
the high road
why the moment you have a guy that's not
passionate the moment you have a guy
that's there to collect deckle take his
fancy car go right up in the suburb
that's the law you say he doesn't care I
got here the moment you do get a guy
that cares about it then we want to
complain you can't have it both ways
like I love the fact that the the
viewpoint from Baker Mayfield
is the same viewpoint he has for you
Jackson the same yes for players like if
you have a player going to an opposite
team or a player playing for a bangle
you know gonna be his buddy you're not
gonna you're not gonna go over there
dampen them up and give them a hug at
the game you won't be in your feelings I
think Baker saw him is the opposition
and I think having that kind of mindset
is okay like being being that Baker
Mayfield saw huge
and take a job it wasn't any took a job
with the bangles actually don't bleed it
I think it was just the fact that he's
now wearing a different logo on his
shirt and Baker Mayfield doesn't see him
as family and I'm okay I'd rather have
Baker do that and where is the most
costly to say he's not family anymore
like that right there's a passionate
quarterback man so you don't mind that
that's the way I feel when I see you on
CBS every Sunday morning against NFL
gameday morning Nate Wright originally
wasn't going to take the job like no
rich guy no no no no you doing look you
do your career the way you need for you
and your family that you've you've
you've crushed it you're killing it it's
a side note taking the job or not I was
looking at my bracelet that I wear all
the time it's wwr the-- and is what
we're rich dude it's okay yeah so when
you come off the set a good good morning
football if I'm there I'm giving you the
whole hug but if I see you coming off
the set of CBS I'm giving you the
extended handshake and you can only give
them a helmet tap that's it okay I'm
just letting you know I mean that's fine
right yeah I'm okay with it
okay just understand where I'm coming
from although I consider you family in
either way Nate I mean so what is your
thought on the the other hot-button tub
topic which is Big Ben after throwing
the game ceiling interception pointing
out various aspects about the scheme
that led to it and the play itself and
where Antonia Brown was running and then
saying this afterwards being around for
a long time dealing with a lot of
different players you have to know how
to motivate different guys in different
ways and I think that's part of being a
leader being a captain sometimes you you
just grab them off to the side and
sometimes you have to be honest with
them I think that I've earned the right
to be able to do that with as long as
I've been here and I'll be just a scrape
on myself as well and in front of you
guys as well what do you think Nate
Big Ben he doesn't a good job of
answering the question without answering
the question and he says a lot of things
that that throws me off now I know
initially Big Ben came out said I'm a
gunslinger and I'm gonna let it go I
just got takes risk not really though
you know big day has to take care of the
ball and I feel like within that office
they have to throw the ball a lot less
you know it isn't about the intercessor
you look at a Super Bowl win in the
Super Bowl seasons he threw some
interceptions in those seasons so you
can't really relate that but I will tell
you this I was looking up this fat big
grin leads the NFL and attempts and
there's never been a quarterback to win
a Super Bowl that has led in a film in
attempts so there's something about
having a significant significant balance
in your offense I know as much as we
pray Connor and up I said he better fit
for this often balance for this offense
maybe he doesn't bring the same balance
because the lady on one field
Big Ben didn't need to lead the league
in attempt so if he scales back on
throwing the ball so much then they can
control the narrative of the game which
turn over the ball that cost the call
but you know Big Ben is always going to
handle it the way he handled the guy to
step up and say blame me first of all
I'm gonna say is always extra when he
talked like we ain't we always say he
talks it's one sentence to many when he
has a soundbite it's just like that one
like he needs to be like a stands and no
one to leave you know that's right it's
no doubt about it and and one thing that
maybe you can front-load for the good
morning football rundowns next week to
your point
needing to run the football more
absolutely and James Connor the last two
weeks has not looked like James Connor
from the first two months of the season
and we are one poor rushing performance
away from the conversation on shows like
this one in the shows like good morning
football of our the Steelers better off
without levy on bail after all that's
coming potentially that's right they
have got the check right that's
it's right there in front of us James
Conner has every chance to remove that
from future run downs on our shows but
that could be that's right there I'm
just front-loading the the conversation
no quite Nate really enjoyed the chat
here and I'll tell you right now what I
told Peter when I saw him in London
Peter Schrager what you guys you and Kay
Adams and Kyle Brent and the whole crew
the production crew you know on Good
Morning football for somebody who was
there from day one of the NFL Network to
see a show create out of whole cloth
something like you guys have created and
become so popular and a mainstay for not
only the NFL Network but for a sports
television is just awesome to see so
keep keep going I appreciate that man
rich I appreciate you and everything you
stand for of course didn't want to sound
the father to the network man so I'll
see you when I get there late but we'll
cross paths more than at the Super Bowl
I'm sure and then we'll hug it out and
then at the Super Bowl on CBS I'll we'll
just handshake is that okay okay great
scenic that's and April the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience